[Música]
foi bom eu só silva na bahia é e só o
fato de voltar nesse palco aqui hoje me
tira de várias estatísticas para as
quais eu fui predestinada eu sou filha e
neta de duas empregadas domésticas que
migraram do norte do brasil no pará para
estudar este em busca de oportunidade
até hoje a minha mãe trabalha como
empregada doméstica e foi com essa com
esse trabalho que ela conseguiu da
estrutura para que eu pudesse estudar e
não ter que trabalhar enquanto criança
eu me formei em comunicação social e na
seqüência fez um mestrado e isso abriu
muitas portas para mim essa história é
muito comum as pessoas da minha geração
que parecem comigo e eu acho que muito
do teu ter conseguido estudar me formar
me expressar e fazer escolhas que me
trazem até que hoje tem a ver com o fato
de eu ter nascido na era das tecnologias
digitais e um exemplo de como a internet
me ajudou foi que teve um tempo que eu
estava trabalhando num projeto de um
filme com meu amigo bruno f duarte
a gente estava construindo uma
estratégia de comunicação e mobilização
para um filme que era o cabelo que é um
filme dirigido pela cineasta esmir tainá
e ela reuniu mais de 60 sessenta pessoas
a maioria mulheres e negras para poder
contar uma história e é um filme que não
tinha muitas estruturas por trás mas o
filme que teve muita relevância o cabelo
acabou circulando muito mundo inteiro ea
gente foi selecionado para o festival
internacional de roterdã e fomos eleitos
o melhor filme da diáspora africana
também no ano passado
nessa época que eu estava fazendo o
cabelo e precisava de alguém para fazer
o site do filme e eu trabalhava no
observatório de favelas que é uma
organização social que fica aqui na maré
e amar é um complexo de 16 favelas com
mais de 140 mil habitantes
e naquela época eu queria fazer mais e
entender mais sobre tecnologia mas eu
não me sentia muito autorizada para isso
e passar pelo observatório foi muito
interessante pra mim porque ali
aprendi muita coisa e conheci muita
gente fiz muitos amigos e também foi
importante para entender enquanto mulher
negra e qual o lugar que ocupa nesta
sociedade
eu tinha uma curiosidade muito grande de
querer fazer alguma coisa para mudar e
transformar o mundo e eu via no meu
trabalho de comunicação uma ferramenta
poderosa para isso sempre simplesmente
porque eu também poderia me comunicar
com mais pessoas e aí você imagina a
revolução que a internet pode fazer na
vida de pessoas como eu né
eu achava que mestrado por exemplo era
uma coisa que não era pra mim e eu
talvez não tivesse tão enganada porque
em 2015
menos de 30 por cento das pessoas com
pós graduação no brasil eram livres
tudo bem tá certo muita coisa mudou de
lá pra cá e graças a políticas com ações
afirmativas mas as opressões
desigualdade contínuo e é preciso que a
gente tenha um olhar bem atento para as
opressões que as mulheres negras vivem
já que nós somos a base da pirâmide
social desse país
e aí um dado que eu acho interessante de
trazer é que há mulheres brancas têm
duas vírgulas 3 mas é mais título do
esquema do que mulheres negras e isso é
uma questão do mundo inteiro mas nessa
época que eu estava querendo fazer
mestrado e ocupar lugares diferentes
eu propus a oab faz pra fazer uma
formação pra gente que fosse focado em
tecnologia e aí elas é o lábio topo ea
gente fez uma rodada hacker especial
para mulheres negras e ali pela primeira
vez eu me senti como uma pessoa não
excluída da tecnologia mas me senti
capaz de ser uma pessoa que pudesse
pensar os rumos que toda essa novidade
os impactos que elas trazem para a nossa
vida pode realmente mudar alguma coisa
ainda trabalhando no observatório eu
participei de duas pesquisas muito
interessante que dão conta de mostrar um
pouco como o comportamento das camadas
mais populares muda quando a internet
começa a se popularizar essas pesquisas
são direito à comunicação rádio direito
à comunicação e justiça racial e humilde
favela e nessa época foi a mesma época
que o passinho explodiu
o passinho sempre existiu nas favelas
mas isso ganha uma outra dimensão quando
os meninos se filmam e jogam no youtube
e também foi uma época que eu dei conta
de entender que a produção de mulheres
negras tanto como textos de blogs um
audiovisual crescia muito então a gente
estava conseguindo produzir outras
narrativas sobre ser negro no brasil
só que tinha uma outra coisa que me
incomodava
quero entender um pouco quem era quem
estava por trás das tecnologias quem é
que produz essas tecnologias eu pensava
ok
já temos uma boa camada de conteúdo a
gente produz conteúdo para essas
plataformas mas quem produz as
plataformas e aí me veio uma inquietação
de pensar quantas cientista e negras a
gente conhece
quantas mulheres negras se formaram nos
grupos nos cursos de exatas nos últimos
anos quantas são programadores quantas
são engenheiros
eu não sei por que esses dados não
existem mas se a gente pensar que gênero
e raça estruturam a nossa sina nossa
sociedade como que a gente pode criar
políticas mais inclusivo e se a gente
não considera essa intersexualidade ea
rodada hacker e naquelas naquela
seqüência de acontecimentos e marcando
um pouco a minha entrada no lab agostini
me convidou pra gente fazer uma maratona
de rodada já que em são paulo ea gente
fez de pinheiros a parelheiros querendo
estimular que mais mulheres tivessem
acesso a essa discussão e foi muito
legal porque a gente pode fazer uma
inversão estimular aqui o capão pudesse
ensinar para pinheiros e chamou a outras
formas de fazer porque quando a gente se
juntou a gente viu que tinha muita
potência esse diálogo entre periferias
entre espaços diferentes entre pessoas
diferentes e aí eu cheguei no lábio
isso realmente marcou a minha entrada no
lábio e o lábio um lugar de aprendizado
de tecnologia e que quer trazer mais
diversidade para a tecnologia é a gente
pensa muito quem é que está por trás
disso e essa idéia de trazer uma
intersecção intersecção entre pessoas e
tecnologia que é fundamental para pensar
uma educação no século 21
e aí cabe dizer também que pra gente
tecnologia vai muito além de software e
hardware
na verdade a tecnologia também é crochê
e bordado e isso fez com que
e essa idéia do make spacey também são
idéias de que a gente pode se aproximar
dessas máquinas de fabricação digital né
e todo mundo que pensa normalmente me
espelho e se acha que é um lugar muito
ligado à máquina digital alguma coisa
alguma coisa ligada assim na linha do
professor pardal
mas na verdade a grande competência
desses espaços são as pessoas é pensar
as pessoas como potenciais
solucionadores de problemas e aí nessa
caminhada
eu comecei a ver várias pessoas que
estão começavam a dar a vida para as
ideias e eu pensava porque só tem
pessoas muito parecidas e diferentes de
mim nesses espaços e foi bom porque eu
podia aproximar um pouco da tecnologia
da minha vida e entender que o crochê
que a minha avó fazia também era uma
forma de tecnologia
só que não era autorizado a dizer que
aquilo era tecnologia e também uma outra
oportunidade que me trouxe fazer uma
outra coisa que foi importante pra mim
tá dentro do lago foi poder trazer
outras mulheres parecidas comigo para
essa discussão
outras mulheres que pudessem
experimentar o que quer fazer e
tecnologia ea parte muito dessa idéia da
cultura make do faça você mesmo porque a
cultura maker é mais do que tudo eu acho
que ela tem uma compra online uma
competência especial que é nos ensinar a
aprender a aprender porque o futuro ele
é muito incerto e as mudanças é a única
certeza que a gente tem então aprender a
aprender é fundamental nesse roller
agente agregou muita gente foi
conhecendo muita gente que estava
querendo entender mais sobre isso e aí
no ano para 1 no primeiro ano da
experiência
eu viajei para a colômbia com vários
ativistas de 10 países e foi muito duro
perceber que eu era uma das únicas
mulheres negras
nesses espaços né e eu queria entender
como é que eu podia fazer para trazer
mais mulheres pré para esses lugares
só que depois eu percebi que isso não
era um problema no brasil isso é um
problema no mundo inteiro porque apenas
4% da startup de tecnologia por exemplo
são comandadas por mulheres negras nos
estados unidos
e aí eu fui em busca de outros jogos né
20% das profissionais são mulheres nas
áreas de tecnologia - de 16
por cento são os que ingressam nos
cursos de computação e 41 por cento
delas existem da área de tecnologia
contrapondo os 17 por cento dos homens e
aí eu fiquei pensando como que a gente
pode saber
e como que a gente pode fazer para criar
políticas que de fato tragam mais
mulheres praças pra esses espaços e mais
do que isso como que a universidade pode
ajudar no combate ao racismo estimulando
que mais pessoas negras se formem em
variadas áreas principalmente nos cursos
mais elitizados como que a universidade
pode ajudar a gente a combater o racismo
eo machismo trazendo mulheres negras
para também participarem dessas
discussões do futuro e eu fui em busca
de muitos dados e eu não achava esses
dados
foi quando encontrei esse levantamento
feito pra galera feito com a galera da
pole jem da usp que diz que em 10 anos
120 anos
nem dez mulheres negras foram formadas
na poli da usp
e aí eu fiquei pensando o que a gente
pode fazer para estimular essa
participação eu realmente não tenho
essas respostas mas eu tenho uma
sugestão de um caminho que é convidando
mulheres negras a pensarem essas
soluções e é assim que a gente tem feito
com a preta lábio
a preta lab nasce muito nesse meu
incômodo de não dizer a única e de não
ver outras mulheres parecidas comigo no
campo da inovação da tecnologia ea gente
fez um mapeamento que em pouco tempo um
mapeamento muito informal que a gente
lançou um formulário na internet em
pouco tempo tinham mais de 600 respostas
de todos os lugares do brasil
eu estava muito curiosa pra saber o que
apareceu que essas mulheres faziam
mulheres negras mulheres indígenas de
que ela estava aprendendo e foi quando
conheci a história da tainá do rio de
janeiro que começou a programar no
youtube e hoje tem uma empresa que com
de desenvolvimento de software que enfim
é faz trabalhos por encomenda
na sequência conhecer a raquel de manaus
que aprendeu a programar com o
ex-namorado e hoje tem uma plataforma
que ensina mulheres ea cassidy salvador
que nunca foi para a universidade e
aprender sobre tecnologia mas que
aprendeu este conteúdo de forma
autodidata e hoje ensina para crianças e
idosos
e aí eu entendi que a gente tinha que
dar um passo além
que era contar as histórias dessas
mulheres porque é muito difícil você
querer sonhar com uma coisa que você nem
imagina que você pode ser e foi quando a
gente conheceu a história de maria rita
por exemplo a maria rita graça casa
grande é uma das maiores desenvolvedoras
que eu conheço e ela trabalha com isso
há mais de 15 anos fazendo várias
plataformas enfim muitos aplicativos
está em pouco tempo um ano e tanto que
ela conseguiu colocar no currículo dela
que ela era uma desenvolvedora tamanha
dificuldade da gente enxergar nesses
espaços está totalmente ligado à
ausência de representatividade e eu fico
me perguntando se a maria rita fosse um
homem que cursou engenharia branco rico
e que talvez nem tivesse freqüentado
tanto as aulas assim enfim e que não
tivesse trabalhado muito
enquanto os sistemas ela precisaria ter
desenvolvido para se intitular uma
desenvolvedora essa questão queria
compartilhar com vocês
bom no levantamento da preta' lab uma
coisa que me chamou muita atenção foi
que a maioria das meninas não aprenderam
tecnologia na universidade ou no ensino
formal ea maioria delas aprender em
centros comunitários pela internet com
os amigos e aí eu me pergunto será que a
gente deve substituir universidade então
claro que não né gente
na realidade a gente precisa criar
experiências mais convidativas para as
pessoas que sofrem um monte de
preconceito tempo inteiro poderem
participar também dessa discussão mas
não é só o acesso
a gente precisa também garantir a
permanência dessas pessoas
uma pesquisa recente mostrou que 170 mil
jovens entre 19 e 25 anos saíram da
universidade ea gente sabe que a ser
razão ela tem cor
ela tem classe social ela tem gênero e
se o futuro ele é tão tecnológico é onde
a gente delega o monte das nossas
escolhas aos algoritmos
enfim essas plataformas digitais que a
gente pouco entende é fundamental que
pessoas diferentes também possam
participar e se expressar nessas novas
linguagens e ele é esse o futuro
realmente é uma tecnológica e ele vai
chegar para todo mundo
nós mulheres negras temos muito a
contribuir ea gente não pode deixar aqui
as maldades do país
se perpetuem hoje então é importante que
a gente possa criar junto a esse novo
esse novo futuro
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]